hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances foster and constants and kissing
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about at
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
[Music]
our amazing expert guest this week is an
evolutionary psychologist of the ANU at
the university of portsmouth dr. Donna
Fleischman
welcome to trigonometry
[Music]
thank you so much for coming on for
anyone who doesn't know what an
evolutionary psychologist is could you
just tell us a little bit about who you
are and what you do sure so evolutionary
psychology looks at the human mind in a
similar way that you would look at any
other kind of adaptations in perhaps
physiology right so birds have wings and
those wings are specially designed to
fly at certain speeds and to catch
certain kinds of prey and in the same
way the human mind has certain
adaptations that have evolved to help us
survive and reproduce and so for example
I study discussed a lot and discussed
has got evolutionary history that's kind
of human specific and the idea there is
that discussed evolved to distance us
away from things that could potentially
contaminate us both toxins and disease
and so there's a reason why things are
disgusting and it's an adaptation to
help us survive and reproduce
for example isn't it true that women
feel disgust more than men it's very
true yeah women are more disgust
sensitive than men overall especially in
the sexual domain so yeah if you look at
there's one very well-known disgust
inventory and it says that there's three
kinds of disgust pathogen disgust sexual
disgust and moral disgust it's a big
question as to whether or not moral
disgust actually exists for real or if
it's just a kind of extension of anger
but yeah women are much more disgust
sensitive in the sexual domain so
there's a huge difference and one of the
studies that I did was I looked at
whether or not so if you if you make men
sexually aroused so if you have them
look at pornography and then you should
have them think about disgusting
possible sexual scenarios they're much
less sexually discussed sensitive when
they're sexually aroused than when
they're not obviously everybody knows
that from being alive from my PhD I did
a study where I looked at women and we
showed them pornography and then we
showed them disgusting things like
corpses people vomiting stuff like that
or we showed them disgusting things and
then we showed them pornography and we
had also a a probe in the woman's
enjoying this this is escalating
and so the probe so the probe shoots out
light into the vaginal canal and the
more aroused the woman is the less light
comes back because that those blood
vessels take take up that light so what
we found is that women who saw
disgusting stuff first they became less
sexually aroused but we don't find that
sexually aroused women I didn't find
that sexually aroused women are less
disgust sensitive so while men become
less discuss sensitive when they're
aroused it doesn't really seem that
women have that same effect as much and
there's a variety of reasons why women
are more disgust sensitive than men one
is just that you know women have a
certain like five or six chances on
average to have offspring and they have
to be choosy err about who they have
offspring with but another reason is
that women are just much more likely to
get sexually transmitted infections and
I've tried to come up a way to talk
about this delicately it's very
difficult but women are we have a pocket
and you don't have a pot you have
pockets too and so basically if a woman
has sex she's much more likely to get
the sexually transmitted infection of
her partner than she is to pass
something on to her male partner if they
have regular whatever penis in vagina
intercourse so we don't know how long
sexually transmitted infections have
been around but women are much more
likely to get them and they have a much
worse disease burden again you know
again so yeah those are a couple reasons
why women are more discuss sensitive and
how do how did you get into study and
discussed as a little girl were you
curious about evolutionary psychology
how did you become who you are so many
reasons so I'm kind of an unusual I'm
just I'm a strange woman generally but I
was kind of a tomboy growing up and my
mother it was like incredibly incredibly
obsessive compulsive disorder would only
wash me in mineral water that she had
boiled and put alcohol in minerals Wow
my father had to bring home water from
the shop she wouldn't wash me in tap
water and she was just incredibly
disgust sensitive about everything was
this in Brazil because I know that you
have Brazilian heritage yeah no there's
only Brazil when I was yeah when I was 3
months old I left Brazil but yeah and so
my mom was really really obsessed with
cleanliness and with contamination and
she got better over time and then I also
spent my weekend
my dad is big into riding horses and my
grandpa was 2 so I spent all my weekends
almost like filthy for mangy animals and
then at home my you know my living room
is all white everything was completely
pristine and so I became really
interested in individual differences in
disgust sensitivity and you often find
that unpalatable sorts of areas of
psychology are the last to be you know
they were the frontiers basically and so
disgust is pretty new nobody really
wanted to study disgust until you know
so disgust is a relatively new area of
research that compared to other things
like I don't know happiness or whatever
else you know fluffier topics so it was
really a niche that I thought I could
get into and it's really important for
all kinds of reasons for health
psychology the you know for sexual
psychology and sexual health and also
dietary stuff is really you know people
they crystallise about what they eat
when they're very young and people often
can't change their diets because it
disgust
even if you know they'll end up dying of
a heart attack if they don't change
their diets so that's all super
interesting and and but I've worked on
for some time I mean I work on different
stuff now but yeah we'll get into that
but we started talking about men and
women at a level I was not quite
expecting but let's brought an ad-lib we
mentioned before we started the show
James James the more memory things like
that as an evolutionary psychologist
what can you tell us about the
psychological differences between men
and women on average that can a
scientifically verified because I think
most people understand the biological
differences between men and women yeah
well increasingly less so but but but
there are kind of basic things that
we'll know but psychologically it seems
like we're kind of always varying
between offensive stereotype and useless
generalization so what what are the
differences between men and women well
so you might expect that you know one
kind of very conservative claim you
could make from an evolutionary
perspective is that men and women should
only differ in domains in which they've
had different selection pressures and
that doesn't sound like a big deal but
it would make a big deal you know so
some of the the big differences between
men and women are in the sexual domain
and I studied with a
evolutionary psychologist called David
buss and he did some really interesting
stuff where he asked men and women for
example how long would you have to know
somebody before you wouldn't reasonably
be likely to have sex with them and how
many sex partners would you like over
your lifetime and things like that and
some of the biggest sex differences are
in that domain and you also see that you
know kind of lesbians and homosexual men
are kind of interesting in this regard
too because gay men don't really have a
limit in terms of female coyness on how
much sex they can possibly have and so
you see gay men have a lot more sex
partners then straight men can
reasonably have because they're not
limited by women's cheesiness as much so
I think the idea that women are choosy
has even been come into question
recently there was a really famous study
by Clark & Hatfield back in the early
90s where they had Confederate
attractive Confederate a Confederate
it's like somebody who's in cahoots with
the experimenters and they went up to a
random undergraduate on the street and
they said hi I've noticed you're on
campus I'm really attracted to you would
you either a go on a date with me be
coming back to my apartment or see have
sex with me and zero percent of the
women said yes to sex and what
percentage of the men said yes to sex
from a random woman on the street and
the one who said no woman coming up to
me who I've never met before I don't
know I'm going do you want to have sex
with me that would be
excuse my language I would feel my
virginity grow back I'll be honest so so
and they also included men who said I
would love to but you know my mother's
in town or whatever the case may be but
something interesting is that 50% of
women said yes to the date so Wow yes
it's it's interesting yeah but very few
said yes to the apartment and there was
these people who said you know that if
you change the rules of the game like if
you tell women they're definitely never
going to be slut-shamed the sex is going
to be good and they will be in no
personal danger then you can get the
averages a little bit closer together
but certainly
you said that you'd be terrified if a
woman came up randomly on to you on the
street and said would you like to have
sex with me you think she was some kind
of bunny boiler so I think men and women
have similarly you know would be afraid
in that situation the idea that there's
a huge difference there I don't know if
that makes sense so that's that one
domain but you also see differences in
another kinds of domains so women have
on average taken care of offspring much
more than men have and in some cultures
you know in kind of modern Western
secular cultures what's called weird
that's Western educated industrialized
rich democracies men and women tend to
converge and take care of offspring more
together but in most cultures men hold
their kids like whatever 15 minutes a
day women hold their kids you know nine
times as long as as men do and they
always know that they're the the mother
of their offspring for example and so
you should see a lot of differences also
in domains that have everything to do
with child rearing and there's also this
difference in the kinds of roles that
men and women have had in terms of
hunting gathering and seeking out mates
warfare it's never been the case that a
band of women have gotten together with
Spears and hand axes to go and kidnap
the men from a neighboring group and
have sex with them like that's never
ever this idea there's kind of a fantasy
and I think it's I the more I've learned
about kind of leftist ideology the more
I think it comes from a really good
place it would be wonderful if human
nature was so malleable that literally
women could be socialized to go to war
to whatever I mean that that would be a
great but OB greatest human nature was
that malleable so I think it comes from
a really nice place but I don't really
think that human nature especially sex
differences are that malleable and so
you see these kinds of differences so if
you look at the research what you see is
that there's this kind of minimization
of personality differences so for
example if you look at extraversion
which is one of the big five personality
factors men and women don't really
differ at the internal
it's of extraversion you'll see women
are more warm than men are and men are
more assertive and sensation-seeking
than women are and so there's a
scientist named Marco del Giudice at
University of New Mexico he's my
evolutionary psych colleague and he did
a really great paper called the distance
between Mars and Venus and he said these
you know these characteristics that men
and women have they don't occur in a
vacuum these personality characteristics
they converge and they correlate
together and so if you look at cluster
of all the masculine personality
characteristics and all the feminine
personality characteristics they
actually is a big difference between
them and that's averaging across gay men
and gay women as well so there's still a
big difference between these two groups
and if you look at the personality
factors as they are like extraversion
agreeableness etc then you'll see
smaller differences or if you look at
very specific things like if you for
example what's-her-name Cordelia fine
did testosterone rex
and she said yes it's true that in these
personality factors they say men are
much more risk-taking than women are but
they didn't ask about certain kinds of
risk like what about the risk of cooking
a souffle that you've never cooked
before like that's that's not but
nobody's gonna kill you okay so one
thing that I've always been fascinated
with is the you know the premise of law
women like a bad boy is that
scientifically true and if it is why so
yeah so I think that is true but well so
it depends on the kind of environment
you live in so there's some idea that
you actually you're malleable in the
interim you know in the beginning years
of your life as to how much you like
these kind of what are called dark triad
characteristics so dark triad is
narcissism Machiavellianism and
psychopathy and those are you know how
great you think you are description
narcissists are actually considered more
attractive than other people who are in
our success really probably because
their narcissism is somewhat informed by
their actual self their actual main
value what we call mate value so I think
more attractive people are more likely I
mean attractiveness and man narcissism
do correlate like objectively if you
think somebody's more attractive they're
more likely to be narcissists and then
whenever I fell out in our
six inventory they're like would things
be better if you ruled the world I'm
like well yes objective so these kinds
of personality characteristics so one
idea it kind of floating around is that
if you are in a volatile environment so
if you're an environment where let's say
you don't have a father around then
you're getting cues from the environment
that either your dad's dead or that this
is not the kind of environment where men
invest in their kids for example well so
if you're an environment where you see
people deceiving each other cheating
each other so what's the best thing to
do in an environment like that is to
have babies that are also going to be
able to be good liars and good at
deceiving and manipulating other people
you don't want to find the most
agreeable nice guy in the world to have
kids with if you're in an environment
that is volatile in this way and you see
this this kind of dichotomy about what
women like in in romance novels so in
romance novels which are the
best-selling books on the planet what
happens is the woman falls in love with
a man who's this bad boy rogue the what
at the top you know they're pirates
served you sir whatever right and then
he becomes so devoted to her that he can
express this devote deep devotion to her
and he's nice to her and agreeable to
her where he isn't to anybody else and
that is sort of this feminine fantasy is
to be with somebody who has the capacity
to manipulate and [ __ ] over and deceive
other people but doesn't sir her as so
in love with her that he treats her
really well and her family and her kids
really really well and that is that's
what really optimally I think women want
because that's the kind of phenotype
that's the kind of man who could succeed
in any environment and he would make the
kind of kids that could conceive succeed
in any environment so he would be nice
to her but he would also be able to
protect her from external danger and
provider whatever is that he believes
for me yeah that kind of thing but if
you're really in a really in volatile
environment you want somebody who can
yet like [ __ ] over other people so
that's like what you often only want and
even women who say like oh I want a man
who's generous yeah you want a man who's
generous but you don't want to come home
and find a [ __ ] sleeping on your sofa
because he decided to bring one home you
want a man who's generous to you you
want a man who's generous to your family
you want a man who always tells you
you're you
essentially that you're right but
there's like a whole manosphere red pill
thing about how much women need pushback
and how women actually test to make sure
that men that they're with actually
still have these kind of bad
characteristics that they could still
fend for themselves and that kind of so
I'm reading I'm sort of writing a book
and I'm probably going to do it very
much but I've started reading some of
this red pill stuff because a channel
for anyone doesn't know including me
what is oh you don't know what red pill
is uh I'm familiar with red pill in the
sense of people who might have been
left-leaning becoming less left-leaning
there's a lot of different red pills
right possibly that's why I'm starting
to get the sense that's not the one
you're talking about no that's not the
one I'm talking about
um red pill is a it's it's men so that
can think the common wisdom is that
women have it worse than men women are
oppressed compared to men and the red
pill like for example in this like red
pill documentary says that actually
women do have some advantages and these
are underplayed relative to men's
advantages and not only that but that
women also do manipulative things to men
in order to get their way that women
have kind of secret power wait is this a
caste J documentary yeah I have seen it
and I've just asked you a question about
something I've seen as AI v not there's
extra red pill stuff it's also like red
pill stuff about you know what's called
[ __ ] testing so yeah what when women
when and and you're I guess you're
blissfully ignorant of the way married
for a long time now so he doesn't even
realize he's getting please tell me
what's wrong so women women whatever do
something called [ __ ] testing and they
do a variety of things to see kind of
what the boundaries are like how much
they can get away with how generous a
man is going to be with them how
compliant he is to her demands
especially if they're unreasonable so if
you make an unreasonable demand of a man
is he just gonna say yes I'll do that or
will he you experienced some kind of
pushback so kind of testing a man to see
if he has the kind of status whatever
ball was whatever you want to call it in
order to push back against you and not
get into your every whim and I think and
I find that women's kind of self-help
books are very often like you go girl
and you're amazing as you are and
there's nothing you need to do to change
in any way shape or form and somebody
will love you just as you are or as I
find men's self-help books are very much
saying you should workout you should be
doing playing chess you should be trying
to sharpen your mind and you also need
to play this game that women are playing
whereas I really haven't read very you
know and I've been trying to read some
women's self-help books that say no you
are a woman and you are playing a game
but you're deceiving yourself about
these games that you are playing and I
find that I'm very self-aware about the
kinds of ways that I am testing things
out and in seeing where men are at with
me and so coming back to the broader
picture of men and women then I'm sure
you've seen the Kathy Newman Jordan
Peterson interview actually yeah no I
started watching it and then it was very
frustrating it was incredible I mean
he's definitely said some things that I
know that the way to get famous and the
kind of intellectual landscape is to say
things without nuance did you say things
with nuance it's never gonna be a
soundbite cuz nobody cares hmm so I know
that I've seen Jordan Peterson
definitely say things in a less nuanced
way but I mean otherwise he wouldn't be
famous if he was totally nuanced right
probably I'm not a huge fan of Jordan
Peterson but in that interview actually
the part of the conversation was very
much the James the more thing he was
trying to explain that the gender pay
gap is not simply down to discrimination
that there are factors like the Big Five
personality trait difference between men
and women so what can you tell us about
the impact of the differences between
men and women on things like the real
world stuff like the gender pay gap for
example so this wasn't this talk wasn't
recorded I probably should record it at
some point but I gave a talk for the
Adam Smith Institute back in December
and I talked a little bit about where
this kind of wage gap comes from and I
hope I get all the details of the study
right but they were looking at people
who started scored very high on
quantitative measures like the SAT men
and women who scored very very high and
they were looking at this kind of elite
intellectual group and they asked the
men and the women in this group how many
hours a week would you work optimally if
you were you know if you had your
druthers which I don't know what
druthers are but they were things you if
you had your druthers how much you know
how many hours a week would you work and
I think far fewer women is like 30 or
40% fewer women said that they would
work more than 40 hours a week and so if
you ask women I think this is the major
difference here if you ask women how
much would you like to work in a week
and how much time would you like to
spend with your family and how much time
would you like to spend with your kids
women say on average I would like to
spend more time with my family and my
kids and less time working than men say
that they would like to and so that's
that's kind of a it's not very well
appreciated but I do think it comes down
a lot to personal preferences and men
are also more willing to kind of work on
call you know there was this study that
was done which showed that uber drivers
like men were making nine percent more
as uber drivers than women were because
they were willing to work more when the
surge came they were willing to make
more short trips they were essentially
showing that they were more willing to
take risks and do jobs that were less
appealing another really interesting
thing about men and women in terms of
the the pay domain is that lesbians make
more than straight women do there is
something called the lesbian wage
premium lesbian privilege lesbians make
nine percent more than what I would do
and you know if you were kind of going
with the kind of typical story and you
said okay well you know lesbians
obviously don't present as gender
typical they often come across as more
butch obviously I think everybody knows
that
of meltdown half so you know this is
what this is idea like oh you know women
are assertive and they act and I think
this is true to some extent that women
who act assertive they're called [ __ ]
you know in in whatever American black
slang you say a man who acts dominant
he's bossed up whereas a woman who acts
dominant is called [ __ ] right I do
think that that happens but you would
think that a woman who didn't act in a
gender typical manner like some lesbians
do would make less money because they
would be oppressed for not fitting in
with the larger gender roles but no they
make more money and I think it's because
lesbians have some of these
characteristics like status seeking
risk-taking the kind of behavior that
more feminine straight women or less
likely to have do you think this also as
well because men are more aware of
status and it's more about men by their
nature we compete with one another for
everything for for partners for whatever
it may be that we're more obsessed with
status therefore were more obsessed with
work and more generating more money so
that we can present ourselves as being
more successful
yeah absolutely so I mean men throughout
whatever evolutionary history have
gotten sex partners and got laid by
increasing their status so um we amend
men have increased their status in order
to get sex partners and you know women
who are high in status I think that
they're desirable I think men also like
intelligent women who are high in status
but I think that if you have a selection
pressure that and status really differs
from culture to culture so this is one
area that I think is malleable if you
made being a stay-at-home dad a really
high status thing then you would see
more men being stay-at-home dads I think
that women should date today at home
that's what never Poplarville right
because I do think that all of this
stuff is really driven by female sexual
choice and so that is a malleable thing
in some cultures there's not really any
cultures where being a stay-at-home dad
is considered the most high status thing
that you can do and men chase status
whatever it is money power land whatever
it is in that particular culture so I
think that is a malleable
characteristic but the fact that men are
seeking status and chasing status I
think is pretty hard to change so you're
saying that the bulk of the gender pay
gap is down to behavior choices choices
yeah because I'm sure an element of is
down to discrimination and we've had
people women on who told us a personal
story about being discriminated because
they're women and we have no reason not
to believe them so I'm sure that's part
of it but the majority of it you think
is down to choices I think the majority
of it is down the choices and yeah I
think I do think that women do have
stories about discrimination but I also
think that that is kind of how its it's
framed and so it's it's nobody wants to
hear a story from a woman who said no
I've never been discriminated against
I've never had any problems and you know
you also see this in other domains like
one of my colleagues did a study where
he asked people who are minorities in
America you know do they do you think
that you're regularly discriminated
against and east-asian said like 80% of
them said rarely or never and something
like 68 percent of black Americans said
rarely or never do they feel
discriminated against and it's kind of
squeaky wheel thing right you the
stories that people here are definitely
those stories in which discrimination
played a very important role and the
same way that somebody might really
overestimate the murder rate because you
hear much more about murders than other
kinds of crime you also hear a lot more
about discrimination than what is
representative and I think in the
general population
well since you touched on that I mean
we've done something controversial men
and women let's lighten up I've been
talking about racism I mean I remember I
can't remember where there was brett
weinstein or another evolution or maybe
it was jordan Peterson wind conversation
on prevalence and they were talking
about disgust being an element of racism
in human beings and the idea was that if
a group of people encountered another
group of people they were quite likely
to get diseases from them yeah and you
talk about this a lot disease being and
disgust and being very closely
interlinked is that and then like why is
there racism why are people racist why
people xenophobic why do this
Wow really they softball so just keep so
there is a disease story that people
have told there's a anthropoids on it's
a piece of evolutionary biologist and he
talks a lot about how if you were in a
group and then there were these out
group people that they would have
carried novel diseases for which you
would not have necessarily had any
defense against I don't think that that
really makes sense and it's but it was a
really popular explanation for a long
time so xenophobia is related to what's
something called pathogen burden so the
more diseases a given country has the
more kind of bad attitudes they have
against out-group people and these
things were related to one another they
thought and they also conservatives and
political conservatism is associated
with how much disease there is in a
given population I don't really know if
one thing causes the other I just think
that if you have more exposure to
various different people then you don't
necessarily consider them your out-group
but there certainly has been selection
pressure over evolutionary history such
that people who look different than you
didn't necessarily follow your social
norms and you would not expect them to
behave ethically towards you so if you
encountered somebody from an out group
which was a group that was different
from you they probably didn't look that
different from you for example so if you
think about the Hutus and the Tutsis
that civil war that happened in Rwanda
those people to be mean to white people
they don't look that different and you
sometimes there was there's just very
very subtle um physiological differences
between them that caused people to get
discriminated against so in the current
society in which we have people from all
corners of the globe and all kinds of
mixtures of all different kinds of
ethnic groups together that is really a
very novel kind of situation where you
know previously out group members they
would have looked almost exactly like
you except they would have had slightly
curlier hair or slightly lighter eyes or
been slightly taller or thinner or
whatever and now you have people who
look really wildly different than you so
there is a certain I think during your
development you exposed to these people
and then
you have repeated interactions with them
and then you're less likely to become
prejudiced but I think that interacting
with people who look very different from
you is always going to have some kind of
fraud evolutionary cognition behind it
because throughout our evolutionary
history you could not expect those
people who looked very different from
you to treat you with the same kind of
moral Accord that they treated their
in-group so you know if for example I
did a study like a long time ago
probably like nearly 10 years ago which
looked at ovulating women and so one
question is we had ourselves was
ovulating women ovulation is the time in
which it's most dangerous to be sexually
assaulted because it's the time when you
can get pregnant right and so would
ovulating women prefer out-group men so
what they find them more attractive
because there's this thing called hybrid
vigor obviously mixtures of two
different ethnic groups those children
tend to be more vigorous than of a
single ethnic group or would they be
more afraid of such men and we found
that ovulating women showed you know
increased aversion to two men who were
black or Latino or mixed-race compared
to other white men and those are the
kinds of interactions I mean that have a
deep evolutionary impact if I was you
know throughout most of our evolutionary
history I would have not encountered
anybody who looked different than me
unless it was probably a very aggressive
interaction although there was some
trade and things like that I don't think
women generally were involved in that
and so it's unclear really how much of a
footprint that has on our minds but it
is clear that it's very easy for example
to lever disgust or fear when talking
about out-group people and you know
every people talk about this example all
the time about how during World War two
East Asians were compared to insects and
cockroaches and how Jews were compared
to rats and vermin about how out group
members are considered to like smell
different or have these various other
qualities that are animal-like and
certainly there is a continuum like a
human animal continuum I'm just thinking
about whether I should go into when
we're quite complicated study I guess I
will so you know what extinction is
right
think she is you have like a let's say
you have a fear reaction like every time
I show you a snake you have a fear
reaction then over time you get
desensitized to it so this colleague of
mine did a study where he showed white
people snakes and spiders and then he
gave them a very mild electric shock or
he showed them white faces or he showed
them black faces and gave them a very
mild electric shock and it's very easy
to pair physiological arousal that is
heart rate increase and skin conductance
increase with black faces if you're
shocked and in white faces - so that
happened
but then as he extinguished that
response as he started showing them
black faces and then no longer shocking
them it took much longer for that
response to extinguish than it did for
their response their fear response - in
group faces and it was similar to the
response to spiders and snakes and
that's where I think this kind of
comparison between animals sometimes
comes from is that you're trying to
leverage that fear response that you
have towards non-human animals towards
out group members yeah I mean but one
point I wanted to make to you is that
human beings have always found a way to
discriminate against to discriminate
other human beings even if they're in
the same Society for instance in the
1950s in the UK like my father grew up
in Lancashire in the north of England
and you were discriminated against if
you were a Catholic and even on the
surface if they didn't know you were
Catholic one way they could discriminate
against you is they'd ask for your CV
they'd check what school you went to Oh
st. Mary Magdalene school and you're not
gonna get this job X why do we do that
even when a person looks absolutely
identical has the same accent there's
almost no difference you can still find
a way to say no you're not part of my
tribe I guess I was just speculate and
say that there is this kind of
motivation but - to make an out-group an
in-group all the time and to think about
these kinds of things I think sport taps
into that in a more healthy way than
other kinds
of in-group out-group kinds of thought
but I I mean I couldn't I couldn't
explain that the whole Catholic I mean I
would come from America where that's not
really a thing so I find that really
difficult to kind of wrap my head around
but I think that perhaps there's just an
appetite for that and certainly if you
have a group of people that you're tight
with like a family or a kin group and
then you say there's this out group and
they're actually trying to exploit us
you'll become much more tightly knit
with that in-group and so maybe there's
a motivation to do that because it
actually helps you get in better with
the people that you're close to
that's just pure speculation though
that's very interesting it's all very
interesting so far well Mike we talked
about out resident before we started
yeah I can I can try to take care of
that yeah whenever he comes on the stage
she picks out a member of the crowd
because you like comedy and like the
guys like yeah I can change that
[Music]
so yeah altruism we talk about effective
answers my mentioned I listen to
lecturers about morality
tell us what effective altruism is okay
effective altruism is the idea that you
should actually I mean so not all
effective altruists are utilitarian but
I'm a utilitarian and the way that I
think about it is that you should try to
engage in actions for example or donate
to charities that actually can create
the most good and Peter Singer has got
an example that he uses all the time for
example if you watch television you'll
sometimes see advertisements for
seeing-eye dogs and to train a
seeing-eye dog puppy it takes about
40,000 pounds it's very very expensive
to train a seeing-eye dog puppy to
become a seeing-eye dog for a blind
person a blind person's companion
whereas for the same amount of money you
could probably save hundreds of people
from becoming blind at all in Africa
from from river blindness so he kind of
makes this comparison is it better to
have one blind person's life become
better because they have a seeing-eye
dog or is it better to prevent possibly
dozens or hundreds of people for
becoming blind in the first place and
effective altruism
considers the relative risks and
benefits of various kinds of actions on
human flourishing but also all sentient
life flourishing so there's kind of
three main strands in effective altruism
right now one of them is non-human
animals which is something that I'm very
focused on so something like the
trillion fish and billions and billions
of animals are killed in pretty horrible
ways and that's actually a pretty low
hanging fruit you could reduce a whole
lot of suffering if for example you
could make clean meat which is now the
big push which is this meat that you
make without actually slaughtering any
animals or raising animals for food I'll
go into that more in a minute and then
there's a decreasing existential risk so
you know by all accounts human
civilization has led to many many happy
lives there are many more happy lives on
this planet than there ever have been
previously and if we could stretch our
resources even further perhaps we could
have
many more billions of happy lives in the
future colonized the galaxy and just
create many happy flourishing human or
other sentient lives but if there was
something like a meteor strike or
political unrest or a huge pandemic it
could either kill many many people who
would go on to lead happy lives or it
could basically take civilization back
to the dark ages we wouldn't be able to
make these strides in technology that
are going to Nabal many many more happy
future lives and then there's also
eradicating global poverty so that's
another big strand of effective altruism
which is helping people in the
developing world because they're much
cheaper to help the people in the
developed world so you can for example
for I don't know three thousand dollars
give or take by malaria nets and by a
year of healthy life or possibly save a
life from malaria so what they do
there's a bunch of different charity
evaluators there's like give well for
example and they evaluate charities as
to how much life does a dollar buy for a
human of flourishing and so that's kind
of the whole effect of altruism lesson
most of the landscape right now is
looking at those three main cause
priorities and I focus a lot on
non-human animals so I've been vegan for
a long time and I am on the board for
something called the sentience Institute
so what they are interested in looking
at is things like how our animals being
killed in crops and what are the best
ways for example to reduce the amount of
sentient suffering on the planet and so
one thing that I generally plug for
people is that you probably don't want
to go vegan a lot of people don't want
to go vegan because it's difficult and
so most of the animals that you eat in
terms of deaths per calorie here are
small animals so if you were to give up
eating fish and chicken and eggs you
would be causing 90% fewer deaths per
year than if you carried on eating those
things because it takes about 200
chickens to make the same amount of meat
as is in a cow for example
and so this is something also Ezra Klein
who I disagree with politically to a
great extent but he starts off all his
podcasts now saying give up chicken if
you give up chicken then you're actually
doing a huge amount to reduce the amount
of suffering you caused yearly because
every chicken meal you eat or every two
chicken meals kills a chicken whereas it
would take you about two years of eating
beef probably to kill account this makes
a huge difference and I don't think that
cows are 200 times more sentient or more
capable of suffering than chickens are
yeah we'll also yeah I mean people
really have I don't know why people like
whales so much like they have like hair
for teeth do the eyes are all [ __ ]
low and their singing is terrible we
should eat whales okay what else would
prunes aren't sentient are they i I
would put prawns I'm not sure where
problems are ugly there yeah they're
like the cockroaches of the sea however
however you know two things about prawns
that are very bad one thing is that
they're fed other fish yeah so if you
need a prawn it's like eating fish that
have univer to breakfast and that's not
good and the other thing is that there's
a lot of slavery in the supply chain for
prawns about a third of people from
Burma or whatever they go somewhere like
Thailand to get work and they end up on
a ship and they sort out what's called
trash fish so if there's a big trawling
net they take out the fish and those
fish are ground up to go into
aquaculture which is for prawns but what
they do is they want to get paid they
get on the ship but then they're out at
sea and they're sometimes just held at
gunpoint for years at a time and never
paid and never able to talk to their
families and so it was a few years ago
and I don't actually know what kind of
strides have been made in this regard
but the Guardian said about a third of
all prawns have slavery in their supply
chain so don't eat prawns okay so no
chicken
you can eat melons yeah we bought us all
rapists yeah so there was a fear there
was a male chasing a female across the
park the other day and then I tried to
sort of fling a bag of groceries to keep
him from chasing the female but yeah it
didn't it there was a chase that carried
on really he didn't care
yeah but tell us a little bit about why
we do what we do were both comedians ah
what is the evolutionary it's getting
late isn't it about to smash us I'm
looking forward to having my carrot
eviscerate don't see but I feel well
actually you in the long-term
relationship as well I feel like
straight depressed because if you're a
young male comedian and your rationale
for doing comedy is to get laid
yeah you have some some right that
actually makes sense where's you and I
probably decreases our chances are
getting laid with our partners because
so so what we're not even home to do it
begging strangers for love so why do
what why do we need to why do we have
humor well what is the evolution basis
for humor okay so start from the
beginning there's this thing called
sexual selection and sexual selection so
natural selection is the evolutionary
force that creates adaptations that
cause you to be able to survive but
sexual selection are the adaptations
that you use to have sex and there's a
famous kind of analogy which is with the
Peacocks tail so peacock produces a tail
and the females find it attractive but
producing a tail that's symmetrical
that's colorful and that he can jiggle
at her he's actually is actually very
costly it makes him more prone to
predation if he has any parasites he
can't grow that tail and so humor is
considered like a costly signal in the
same
it's hard to be funny as you both know
very difficult to be funny and so one
idea actually Jeffrey Miller who is my
partner came up with what didn't come up
with but wrote a book about in the
mating line is that human intelligence
is a costly signal it actually takes a
lot of energy you have to have
development that has you know very
little disease in it in order to be
smart enough to do things like make art
or make jokes and so it's a costly
signal you're saying look at how brainy
I am look how intelligent I am I can
make you laugh because it's very
difficult and so they've done studies
for example where they had
undergraduates caption various different
cartoons and people who are funnier also
tended to be smarter right and so and so
the idea is that humor is a way of
showing off how healthy and vigorous you
are because you're actually wasting your
intelligence a bit it's it's like a
costly signal just like a diamond is a
way of wasting your money humor is a way
of showing look I'm so smart that I can
afford to show off in this particular
way and in order to make somebody laugh
you have to also have pretty good kind
of theory of mind your brain has to work
really well so I have to have some idea
of the culture that you come from I have
to have some idea of the kind of popular
culture that you might know I have to be
able to not be too obvious I have to
have the kind of correct timing I have
to be quick but I have to also speak
clearly it's a whole thing it's knowing
your audience yeah it's also knowing
your absolute know your audience yes
staring away from the vague enjoys
difficult to be funny so men tend to
show off in this particular way more
than women I'd like to think I'm a funny
woman but like I don't actually think it
really gets me anyway it gets me
somewhere with whether women like I date
women and women certainly like that I'm
funny but I don't think men care I mean
the men that I date tend to care that
I'm funny but I don't think I would have
any problems if I was totally totally a
wet blanket and not funny at all and you
know when I used to hang around with
these people who were in the military
and they were on this military base in
Germany and I found that all the men
tried to learn German
conversational in German so they could
try and pick up German women and none of
the women who lived on this military
base even those who were on partnered
learn Dani German because they didn't
have to because German men tried to
speak English with them and then the
American men who were on this german
military base were learning german so
they could seek out women and so men
have to try a lot harder and I think
that's where humor kind of comes in so
you're saying that that's essentially
all humor is it's a tool to try and get
laid and that's the cause well do you
think because there's a stereotype that
the more the better-looking you are the
less funny the less interesting you have
to be is that true or is that just a
words Harriette I had this friend who
she was she was really obese and then
she had gastric bypass surgery and that
she was really thin and it was she's
really funny and people always said oh
now I know why you were funnier you see
[Laughter]
because you have to show off right so I
do think people don't work harder than
they have to work in general right yeah
I mean I think that I thought I was
really really ugly until I was you know
well into my late late teens
yeah and I think that I would be pretty
boring if I thought it was attractive
earlier right and I think that's yeah
the same way with with people just work
as hard and they they people tend to
play to their strengths and if you find
out that you're funny then you'll really
work on that because everybody has a
niche and you'll try and play up that
and become as good at that as you
possibly can and if you're attractive
that's just a way easier way of
signaling your quality than being funny
right and and people generally don't
tend to cultivate being funny unless
they really have to I love the moment
where you win basically you know being
funny is a way of wasting your
intelligence am I am I talking to my
mother
conspicuous consumption of brain energy
yes I'm not that kind of psychologist we
do anything else you particularly wanted
to ask about humor was anything else EU
particular I feel suddenly on depression
now what why do you think so it comes to
a point where women find humor
particularly attractive and do you think
if a woman what do you think is more
important for a woman evolutionary is it
being sound of healthier body or healthy
of mind which one will be more desirable
I mean those things tend to correlate so
people have all kinds of stereotypes
about for example people think if they
think about a scientist or they think
about somebody highly intelligent they
don't also tend to think about somebody
who's very attractive and very healthy
and very athletic right
even though good characteristics tend to
cluster together so people who are
really good with other people also tend
to be smarter but when we think about
people who are highly intelligent we
tend to think about people who are
highly intelligent and then have a
deficit and other characteristics like
how well they can read other people for
example right and those things that's a
stereotype that we kind of have about
scientists and and funny people so in
general if you're smart enough to make
jokes you're also going to be have
pretty healthy other factors right it's
pretty hard to be smart enough to make
jokes if you're I don't know dying of
consumption just swing back to that kind
of dark triad narcissism
Machiavellianism psychopathy I think
that there's a certain degree of showing
how good you are at exploiting other
people in humor because you're figuring
out something there's a lot of jokes
that are tapping into things that people
don't want to admit to themselves that
they believe or taboo ideas that
everybody holds or weird things that
people do that they think nobody else
knows about and so that's another reason
why humor is attractive because it shows
that you have this secret knowledge of
other people and that is one of the
necessary ingredients for being able to
exploit other people
[Music]
brilliant and if you don't mind me
asking where are you politically because
he fainted Thanks yeah where am i
politically uh I was really like I was
kind of a socialist in my early 20s
believe it or not everybody is yeah and
and I read on Rand and then that swung
me a bit and then I thought Anna and is
a terrible person that swung me a little
bit the other way and so there's been
back and forth but there's not really
any libertarians here and the in the UK
but I guess I would define myself as
somebody who is libertarian leaning but
also thinks that there are some services
that the free market can't really
provide very well and I have joked
before I think I made a joke on Twitter
that said if you want to keep your male
partner away from women encouraged him
to get into libertarians are very very
yes like 75 percent male a very very few
women libertarians alright yeah cuz I
would say this is this podcast is fairly
libertarian leaning I'm certainly a
libertarian I don't know well I don't
know what I am anymore but one thing I
was actually going to ask is this do you
think you touched on it very early on at
the beginning of the podcast do you
think I mean in a world we'd all love to
live in a socialist paradise but we're
all weak or everybody's happy we will
listen to each other yeah but do you
think essentially human nature those are
fun delete it fundamentally incompatible
with the basics of human nature
listening to each other
yeah socialism in many ways you know
this idea you know socialism communism
the four left-wing ideas of how we
should live I think it's a quote
attributed to EO Wilson about socialism
which is a great idea but the wrong
species yeah you know cuz the ants do
that really well yeah yeah and naked
mole-rats
parents are all related on that yes
right and never saw a naked mole-rats
right I just think it's it's very
difficult especially you think about
something like Twitter or sound bites
when people are trying to talk to one
another the tweets that are most popular
are tweets they're saying like well no
one else is brave enough to advocate
this moral position but I'm really
strongly
advocating this moral position in a
totally unknown stand direct way and so
if you want to have a tweet go viral or
you want to have a lot of people listen
to you then you have to give a fairly
unknown position and it's it's not
anyone's is really not encouraged in
really any culture and it's a little bit
alarming to think that it's probably
more encouraged in our current culture
than it has been at other points in
history and what you have to do is you
have to play to the whole IQ
distribution right you have to play to
people who could not understand nuance
it to fit them in the face and then you
have to play to people who really only
speak in very nuanced terms and have
very complex ideas about things and so
there's always going to be that problem
with populism is that people can have
nuanced positions but they have to
present them in in this other way and
then I think that's something that
happens with leftist politics is that
they want to throw out people with their
ideas so there's this kind of hygiene
epistemic hygiene where if I think that
you have like let's say you and I were
talking and you expressed some kind of
opinion that I thought was bad you think
everybody should eat as many chickens as
possible you said something like that
then I might say now I think that all of
your ideas are bad and I'm going to
completely reject you and even ideas
that you have that I might otherwise
agree with because I can't think about
you and I says you know as a group of
ideas I have to reject you as a person
and that's something I think is really
difficult in the kind of current climate
is this desire that people have to
reject you know so Jordan Peterson I
disagree with him about a lot of stuff I
think he's actually very traditionalist
in a lot of ways that I don't think are
very helpful and there's some things I
disagree with that and I like sam harris
about there are some things I disagree
with jeffrey miller about there's a lot
of people that I admire and I have
fundamental disagreements with them but
what happens now is that the more and
more different attitudes are moralized
for example if I said I don't think
there should be any welfare state I
don't know if I could totally advocate
that position but that's the kind of
thing that I could say that would make
somebody say well now I'm also going to
reject veganism I'm also going to reject
evolutionary psychology I'm also going
to reject all these other ideas that I
think are clustered together with that
and I have this philosopher friend named
Amanda oskol and she said that one
really good way of getting around that
is to communicate to people that you're
talking to you that you share values and
so if you're talking to somebody about I
don't know welfare or socialized
medicine or whatever you'll say I don't
want to see people die in the street I
also care that people live and have
happy lives
and then you start a lot to kind of same
page whereas I think what happens a lot
of times people will think well you're
not advocating the same position that I
am so you are a moral monster who also
doesn't care if people die on the street
and who doesn't care about human
flourishing and if you kind of start off
saying you know we have similar values
then you can then talk about how you're
gonna arrive at those values in
different ways but unfortunately the
ways that we arrive at those things like
for example if I said I believe in sex
differences and I believe they're
pervasive and I believe that there's a
lot of things that we can't really do
much about in terms of sex differences
then people might also ascribe to me the
belief that I think that women should be
kept at home or they should be told what
to do when I don't have that value at
all I just have a different idea about
how we might arrive at gender equality
then and I have a different view and
what that means that other people would
for example but isn't it also
intellectual laziness so for instance if
you say one thing then instead of me
actually taking the time to find out
everything about you your points of view
how I'm certain incidences you're on the
writer sentences you're on the left and
certain instance your centers it's more
easy to go or your this this and this
and this therefore I want nothing to do
with you yeah absolutely and in the same
way that you were saying like people
exclude Catholics and you know that
there's been these these ideas about
making in groups in making out groups it
is some degree intellectual laziness but
also it's much easier to kind of push
somebody away who has a bunch of nuanced
positions and then say now we stand
strong me and the other people who are
in my ideological in-group and if
there's a threat from people with these
other kinds of positions then you can
become much tighter knit and you see
that in all kinds of different Facebook
groups I've been on Facebook in a year
and a half actually partly because I had
a really horrible argument with one of
my best friends
on Facebook publicly and yeah and so
it's I actually prefer Twitter because
even though people are actually I've
cultivated a really reasonable following
even if I say this person said something
stupid very rarely do my followers go
after them in a way that I'm embarrassed
about
so I maybe I'll undo that but I don't
really care people people say crazy
things to people on Twitter but on the
other hand you know those responses are
there have to be short somebody responds
to you 20 times then them they and
everybody else who's watching them knows
that they're probably going on too much
whereas Facebook I just didn't want to
read novel-length the responses from
people anymore about stuff that I had
posted about so I haven't really been on
there also my mum didn't water
listen let's wrap up now tell me about
this current climate that you refer to
do you think you know we talk about free
speech a hell of a lot you know
comedians we're naturally drawn to that
issue anyway is we hear from America
that people like Prayer weinstein
heather herring etc there's there are
issues apparently at American
universities where certain things are
becoming impossible to researcher to do
do you find that that's the cage you
think that's a true and do you think
it's the case here in the UK is
affecting science this climate that we
have now I mean where I teach I can say
pretty much whatever I want and I've
even I was on some podcast was it oh no
I was on some late-night
and now it's on late-night reruns I told
an incredibly dirty joke on television
and nobody really gives me any flack
about anything at all at my university I
also teach psychology human sexuality
and I teach about some quite edgy things
and I've never had any pushback about
anything whatsoever some of my students
have said Diana teaches us things from a
certain perspective and I don't always
agree with that perspective but of
course I'm gonna teach things from a
certain ideological perspective and if
somebody writes in their exam paper
something different than my perspective
if they back it up with evidence I would
still really appreciate that right I
don't get that impression over here
and in the United States I know a lot of
people you know Jonathan hi Jeffrey
Miller Sam Harris
christina hoff sommers people like that
who had some kind of pushback but I also
think they wouldn't be nearly as famous
as they are now if they hadn't had
protests and pushback and one thing that
I really like that Jordan Peterson said
is that if you scheduled a talk for him
at 8 a.m. or 9 a.m. there would be no
protests yes
it's very hard for these people to I
mean I'm not gonna disparage them too
much but it's pretty hard for them to
aggregate very early in the morning
they're not that well organized that's a
lovely way of saying later so there's
there's I mean I'm still pretty agnostic
about that I haven't lived in the States
and some time and I also am in a sort of
privileged position as I'm a woman I can
say kind of what I want sorry I think
yeah I just feel like I can kind of say
what I like and and very few people have
ever given me pushback about those
things did you think if you're a man you
wouldn't be able to say some of the
things that you say yeah I don't think
so I thought think I could talk about
sex differences in the kind of facet
moocs way that I have and today you know
on this podcast if I was a man because
people would feel like I was ideological
but biased you know in favor of my own
sex whereas as a woman it would really
behoove me to say women are very
oppressed and I should be given kind of
more advantages or concessions because
of that and that would actually be the
the best position for me to take in
terms of my own self-interest and so if
I'm arguing kind of against my
self-interest people are more likely to
trust that and then also you know it's
yeah I think petering out here yeah I'm
sorry I'm latina as well so I think I
also have a bit of leeway about things
in that respect but you know I think
that what happened to to Brett Weinstein
is terrible but I also think that he was
at a very weird University yeah
I went to a really super lefty liberal
arts university I was not politically
involved in anything at that time really
and so I didn't really see much of that
but I'm pretty sure that if I had
started inviting libertarians or
christina hoff sommers or anybody like
that to come and speak I would have also
experienced that kind of pushback but at
the current climate and this is this is
something that people who like you know
libertarians and people who like the
free speech people are not going to
appreciate me saying I think that
they're actually getting a whole lot
more benefit out of being protested than
they are experiencing drawbacks or
detriments I would agree with that but I
think the point that they would probably
make is that they're not after Fame
they're actually trying to achieve
something in terms of making sure that
people can speak freely
general I'm saying so they personally
benefit absolutely but I think a lot of
them do so almost without intending to
well if they're trying to get to a
bigger audience certainly they're
getting to a bigger on yes that way and
and I think that it obviously it boobs
them to say oh I'm really just trying to
speak truth and these people are trying
to prevent me from speaking I think what
happened to Christina Hoff Sommers I
watched some of that or people
unplugging the microphones and things
unfortunately if I was involved in
leftist politics or I was involved in an
Tifa I would be embarrassed about how
childish people in my in-group were
coming across and those kinds of
interactions and so it's really making
people who have sometimes very edgy
political positions look really good by
comparison and I wouldn't really pull
too much on that thread because it's
working out very well
I think that's far right but there are
certain things I think that are very
difficult to research and I think that
that's going to kind of unwind at some
point we're gonna have to you know
behavioral genetics is really making
leaps and bounds previously you know
just looking at somebody's genes you
really wouldn't know that much about
their personality and now we're going to
you know I think in 10 or 15 years be
able to give pretty tight confidence
interval about how agreeable how
intelligent how how promiscuous like all
kinds of things about people based on
their their genes and we're going to
know how much things
genetically determined and how much
things are influenced by environment
much more so than we do now and there
just won't be any way around that so I
think people who are ideologically
motivated against that position now
because there's not a whole lot of
evidence that you know genetics is so
deterministic in all these different
respects but I think is that kind of the
evidence mounts you're gonna see that so
I think a lot of these problems will
kind of sort themselves out very good
thank you so much for coming on listen
the last question we always ask our
guests is is that one thing that you
think no one's talking about that we
ought to be talking about or if you
can't think of some of that is that one
thing we haven't talked about today that
we should have talked about okay yeah I
think that kind of the last point that I
was making about the kinds of strides
that behavioral genetics are making and
then also you know in China they're
trying to figure out ways of getting
people sort of a social reputation score
social credit yeah social credit things
like that and they're trying to run
their society in a sort of tighter way
to see I mean they're basically trying
to promote social order in a way that's
totalitarian and I think that one thing
that people aren't really talking about
enough is that when all nations have
access to that kind of technology when
you can with a DNA sample or a picture
of somebody's face figure out kind of
the likelihood that they're going to
have certain kinds of characteristics
how are people going to use that kind of
information and how can we promote a
free society when that kind of
technology is really available to
everybody and I'm not sure how soon
that's all going to happen and I don't
know a ton about it right now
but I do think that it's super important
and people aren't talking about it oh
sorry yeah it's already happening people
Algrim who I mentioned that we had on
the show a few weeks ago she's an expert
in technology and she was talking about
the fact that it's already happening
yeah it's already they're already doing
it the scary stuff yeah scary stuff well
that's a nice positive note all right
Donna Fletcher thank you so much for
coming in it's been a pleasure tell tell
us what is your Twitter handle
it's sentient issed scientists yes so
somebody who prioritizes sentence as a
basis for morality and yeah I'm Diana
Fleischman comm is where you can see my
public
another and you're writing a book I am
writing a book proposal okay yeah I'll
be blogging and stuff probably come back
and talk to us when the book is
generated love - yeah we'll talk about
genetics more that would be fascinating
thank you
all right just before we go could if
you've enjoyed it could you please write
the podcast I'm enjoying how Frances are
looking at the wrong camera could you
please write the podcast five stars
leave review or even better tell a
friend that you really enjoyed it and I
think someone wants to follow you up
fading human and I'm a constant in the
kitchen follow us at trigger pod on
Twitter subscribe to our YouTube channel
we're building up or did our audience
and we'll be back next week with another
so thanks very much
[Music]